on attrape un rhume à cause du froid et
des courants d'air alors le rhume c'est
une maladie c'est une infection des
voies respiratoires supérieures qui est
causé par un virus et ce virus il se
transmet par la salive ou les sécrétions
respiratoires soit par contact direct
vous voyez ce que je veux dire hein soit
de façon
aéroporté non aéroporté ça veut juste
dire transportter par
l'air à vos sou transporté par n'importe
quel type d'air pas juste l'air froid ou
des courant d'air la seule raison pour
laquelle il y a plus de rhume l'hiver
c'est qu'on reste tous enfermés à
l'intérieur les uns contre les autres
fenêtres fermées et donc on se refile
plus facilement nos germes c'est tout
bon alors oui quand il fait froid on a
le nez qui coule c'est vrai mais c'est
juste parce que la muqueuse est agressée
donc elle sécrète plus de mucus et qui
coule vers l'avant au lieu de couler
vers l'arrière dans les fausses nasales
comme d'habitude mais ça coule propre
parce que c'est pas infecté donc c'est
pas une maladie